Falls with us in California hey Paul
welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey what's
going on guys this is my situation out
in California we got a bunch of
convenience store owners out here and
you know we do what we can for our
employees you know sneeze guards face
shields everything and now what's
happening is that with $600 gavin newsom
decided to give two people each week on
top of whatever you would get on
unemployment we have employees that are
not showing up to work and we're not
firing them they're where they just
start usually not to go to work and then
they're filing for unemployment and over
here there's just the unemployment the
way they're checking it it's so backed
up it's a mess that what do we do to
prevent this from like fraudulent
unemployment because then that money
comes out of our pool yeah that's true
well it's not gavin newsom it was the
feds gavin newsom was their statement
it's a state unemployment the feds gave
came out as the Care Act $600 additional
unemployment from the federal government
until July 25th and so I don't know I
think you've got a clogged up
bureaucracy you you reporting these
folks and firing them is going to set
them up to me if you fire me and I set
them up for unemployment so but in
reporting them for fraudulently doing it
yeah I don't know I mean if they're
taking it anyways I feel like you you
fire them you document it and they're
gonna collect unemployment either way
I'd rather them collect it and you not
be paying them you guys took the PPP
loan is that correct
no yeah we have quite PPE loan and you
know working on that and whatnot but
sounds like you don't want well I
wouldn't I mean because it'll gated to
keep your employees if you're going to
get that thing forgiven and so I would
say tap the brakes on the PPP loan get
rid of the team that is close employment
not showing up and hire some people who
want to work now you gotta let them know
yeah I'll let them know you're gonna
hold them accountable you don't have to
get into the bureaucracy side of it but
I'm gonna tell you something right now
there are people that need to work and
I'd start I'd start you know hitting the
bushes and telling people hey we've got
opportunities for you to make money
right now
unfortunately though Dave we talked
about this with art Laffer today this is
a real thing this cares
has created this incentive to stay home
and boys asking to be late offer yeah
they're making way more money because
these are hourly wage earners Daniel and
so they're making way more but here's
the reality you know July 25th is
looming okay it's coming and and you
know a lot of people who need work and
so I'd move on I absolutely move on I'd
say I'm gonna hold you accountable and
that nothing against you but we've got
to get people in here that it want to
work and I'd go get people that want to
work well then I want business owners
right now to realize that they do not
have to participate in the incompetence
by the Fed I mean that Congress is best
day is is your worst day and I know some
of them are trying and other trying to
put stuff together to help I think their
hearts are probably to really help
people out but they're competent to
design a plan I was gonna question
trying to be great very nice I mean the
truth is that you can't wait on Congress
to get this problem solved you got to
solve